ah oui un dribble de coûts ouais
exactement c'est un exercice peu
ordinaire pour ces lycéens à
l'initiative de leur professeur de psc
élèves ont eu un avant-goût des
prochains jeux paralympiques
assis dans des fauteuils roulants de
sport ils ont pu découvrir une
discipline totalement inédite
c'est compliqué parce que on n'a pas
l'habitude et après pour tourner
comprend
si le fauteuil se décline au tennis de
table ou encore au tir laser
c'est un autre sport qui a donné
beaucoup de difficultés à ses élèves le
torball un sports pour déficients
visuels avec un ballon muni de grelots à
l'intérieur bah ça fait du bien de
revoir ce que pendant 15 minutes on voit
rien et c'est très déstabilisant
pourquoi lorsqu'on voit rien on perd
complètement un sens on sait plus où ce
qu'on est personnellement ça va assez
angoissé de pas savoir où j'étais
j'ai eu peur de me prendre la balle en
fête dans ce lycée professionnel ses
élèves suivent une formation d'
accompagnement soins et services à la
personne est ici le handicap ce n'est
pas que du sport dans les cours on doit
avoir obligatoirement les différents
publics donc la petite enfance la
personne malade la personne en situation
de handicap
je trouvais ça aussi intéressant de
l'associer avec le ps
et ça leur amène de la sensibilisation
c'est vrai que se mettre à la place de
la personne c'est vrai que c'est aussi
intéressant parce que plus tard elles
seront professionnels donc c'est quand
même vraiment très très bien en france
plus de 5000 établissements scolaires
participent à cette semaine olympique et
paralympique